ein sturz mit folgen ein neues bett muss
her
im film borek hebräisch für schraube
bestellt die israelische künstlerin
metall bei einer möbelfirma ein bett zum
selber zusammenbauen
doch eine schraube fehlt mich als klage
wird der palästinensischen arbeiter in
latin welche die schrauben bei der
möbelfirma abfüllt zum verhängnis in
raffinierter parallelmontage wechselte
film zwischen der arabisch
palästinensischen unter jüdisch
israelischen lebenswelt hin und her
die beiden frauen kommen sich im verlauf
der geschichte immer mehr
beide frauen bin ich alles im film bin
ich die charaktere meine gefühle
meine fantasie
ich fühle mich beiden charakteren sehr
ähnlich
borek zeigt beide seiten die harte
realität der palästinenserin hat die in
ein flüchtlingslager lebt und täglich
israelische checkpoints passieren muss
und die ängstliche hilflosigkeit der
soldaten die demütigung an den
grenzkosten kennt die regisseurin gut
sie beobachtete gemeinsam mit einer
israelischen frauengruppe die
geschehnisse an den kontrollposten tage
lang in dem moment in dem ich mit
eigenen augen sah was da passierte
schwor ich mir nicht mehr länger zu
schweigen
ich beschloss meine erlebnisse in meinen
nächsten film zu verwenden
wie auch immer jetzt sagt schira gefen
ihr berührendes und aufrüttelndes werk
am zurich film festival
hier geht es bedeutend friedvoller zu
und her als ein karussell im film
festival
dort protestierte sie mit anderen
regisseuren gegen die israelische
politik forderte vor der filmpremiere
eine schweigeminute für die getöteten
kinder in gaza die mutige aktion hatte
folgen
die reaktionen auf mein und meines
mannes engagement für den frieden waren
extrem
es gab drohungen und verwünschungen das
war wirklich beängstigend von den
israelis
der film zeigt auch verfehlungen auf
palästinensischer seite subtile kritik
gehüllt in verführerisch schöne bilder
zu reale bizarre und märchenhafte
elemente lassen dabei die grenze
zwischen realität und fantasie
verschwimmen
wahrheit sind den schrägen humor
verpackt lässt die palästinenser und die
israel in ihre rollen und identitäten
tauschen und führt so den konflikt der
beiden bevölkerungsgruppen hat absurdum
wenn wir verstehen dass mein leiden
dasselbe ist wie dein leiden
dann wird die situation besser werden
gegenseitiges verständnis als ausweg aus
der verfahrenen situation china gipfels
film macht hoffnung